it was perhaps an unusual way to confirm
a case of a highly infectious
potentially deadly virus taking off his
mask at a news conference he said to
show he was okay while announcing his
own test result el paseo de Paseo de
contest even a person brevis Toyotomi
apart exposes own he agravado Rancho
Diego de Ferran
como esta cansá pokey do a muscular
Yaffe throttle show gravity Nieto
integrals de resolve in tow
question Tomas de comercio da
presidencia upon todo para a
contamination pelo coalfields an RV for
most fazil tomography Hospital does
first arm Isaac in Brasilia even in
testing positive Jaya balsan ro showed
his approach to Kovac 19 has never been
Orthodox few world leaders have done as
much to downplay the risks to the virus
in the face of what he calls a little
flu he's often defied even judge's
orders to wear a mask even at the
weekend meeting the US ambassador to
Brazil for lunch he's now being tested
to all the while the deaths have piled
up in Brazil 65,000 people have lost
their lives 1.6 million have been
infected for the poorest it's often a
choice between buying a mask or buying
food like his close ally in the US
Brazil's president has been dismissive
of the risks and even now is touting the
drug hydroxychloroquine
as a treatment the World Health
Organization says his positive test is a
warning to everyone I think it brings
home for us all the reality of this
virus and no one
is special in that regard we were all
potentially exposed to this virus the
virus citizens really know who we are
whether were Prince or pauper we are
equally vulnerable the question is
whether his own positive test will
change bolsa Narrows approach to the
virus the indications so far suggest not
Greg Milan Sky News